look at this another hotel room hey guys
sorry that the Friday video is not
Friday raid nor is it really up on a
Friday Oprah - just how it like my
possible pregnancies I'm down at San
Diego comic-con for a very brief moment
in time because I just did @midnight
live which was really fun with Steve
Agee and Brian Hussein and
what's-his-face Oh Chris Hardwick yeah
the gang was all day so I didn't have
time to make a video today so I make you
one right now I decided today I've been
watching a bunch of these videos because
they're a little addicting because as
Watchers that the Internet is we like to
know everything about them so I'm going
to do the TMI tag they're too much
information tag and I don't know if I
can give you too much information
because I have the power in this video
to not do that let's get started there
are 50 questions mother what are you
wearing what kind of pervert made this
tag I'm wearing a sweater that like this
my style icon is a square where's the
sweater from where is this do you really
care yeah H&M ever been in love yes love
cake ever had a terrible breakup
um yeah sorta this tag you don't have to
elaborate it's really great I'll tell
you I'm five foot nine how much do you
weigh about shoe any tattoos no but for
the first time in my life recently I had
like even the slightest urge to have a
tattoo I have never ever wanted to
I'm a very indecisive person and I know
that I can't think of anything that I
would want forever so I thought maybe I
get tattoo behind my ear that's just one
dot any piercings of two holes in
my ears really has been a great
investment because I love wearing
earrings every day OTP Michelle and
Barack Obama no Michelle and Michelle's
arms yeah they're just so great together
favorite show Real Housewives any
franchise I haven't gotten into the
Miami once as much all the faces
beautiful girls support each other
favorite bands
ugh band-aids a triple I something you
miss my dog I miss her a lot don't worry
just going back soon it won't be patient
I have been favorite song right now what
am i listening to
oh right now I've been listening till we
didn't start the fire I decided that I
needed to have a karaoke song recently
and I really like that song so I've just
been listening to it to try and enter a
secret how old are you 28
zodiac sign Libra Oh jinx kale what else
got like Kahlua scorpion fish goats that
shoot arrows and I am a scout let me
tell you how much you're produce plays
quality you look for in a partner funny
ambitious and passionate and kind and
nice those are qualities instead of
quality just like this video
we don't copy favorite quote at the
moment its each I guess I had find a bit
of quote favorite actor I like Chris
Hemsworth a lot and Liam Hemsworth I
like all the Hemsworth
what's a Hemsworth priceless favorite
color
I love navy blue cream and gray I am a
human j.crew ad loud music or soft when
I'm running I like loud music when I'm
having to think I like no music when I'm
chilling I like soft music I have layers
where do you go when you're sad inside
my body I refreshed row number 21 Jesus
Christ how long does it take you to take
a shower it depends if I have to take a
[ __ ] not because it's kind of part of my
shower routine how long does it take you
to get ready in the morning it takes me
probably like half-hour to an hour to
get ready then like another power of
just putzing and forgetting everything
that i need to bring with me ever been
in a physical fight with my brothers but
never with stranger and I hate violence
so so much I hate fights I break out
into hives if I see them happening it's
just a really fun human experience turn
on let's turn on
Oh when someone's really thoughtful turn
off when someone's me the reason I
joined YouTube just complete and utter
narcissism fears sharks death loneliness
needles so that's a really great sci-fi
movie last thing that made you cry oh I
was watching Restaurant Impossible on a
flight recently as I was almost in tears
because hormones last time you said you
loved someone
today meaning behind your youtube name
it's me last book you add my own because
I have to keep writing it till it gets
to the final stage the book you're
currently reading my own crisis
guidebook calm last show you watch Real
Housewives of New York
no I watch Oh Real Housewives of New
Jersey yes don't get those to compute
the relationship between you and the
person you last texted who did I last
text oh it's pretty cool favorite food
Oh cold leftover fried rice is probably
my all-time favorite food or cold cold
pad thai ah place you want to visit
there are a lot of places in Europe I'd
like to see that I've been to in Germany
I haven't seen that there's stuff there
so you'll be seen last place you were
here and before here at midnight at the
Balboa theater in downtown San Diego do
you have a crush of course last time you
kissed someone of recent times last time
you were insulted Oh constantly on the
internet favorite flavor of sweet
chocolate and peanut butter I know it's
- but this is my TMI what instruments do
you play the skin flute I'm really gonna
tugging at your heart strings
by favorite piece of jewelry I like I
wear this ring a lot I like that a lot
last sport you played tennis last song
you sang this song right now I want to
break free I want to break free and I'm
the licensing for it nothing I don't
know the words favorite chat-up line
this is definitely made by a pedophile
to find out things about young girls my
favorite chat-up line is ASL have you
ever used it right now wait for you to
respond send last time you hung out with
anyone right now you guys who should
answer these questions next Hannah and
mamrie also Miranda thank you I hope you
enjoyed the TMI tag
did you really learn anything about me I
don't know guys don't forget that there
are still tickets available for the
nofilter shows that are coming to New
York DC Austin Los Angeles and San
Francisco so please go get yours our
links down below